so i think the the easiest line to cross
i mean nancy pelosi chloe's saying it's
for the children it's for the children
uh so it's not about the children with
them
it is about the children with individual
families and moms and dads that's why
you saw the pushback coming at school
that's why you saw i mean i have friends
who are very
liberal thought who could never have
voted for anybody but joe biden
that are really smoked right now and the
tipping point was you wait
you want to vaccinate my little my
little ones are you kidding me
never
it is our children that speak to us that
make us much more
brave
you know it's interesting i actually
heard you talking about this this
empathy with ai and the robots and that
even when they show the when you see the
robots that we have now
they cannot show true human emotion they
do these things that actually look
completely
counter to human emotion when they try
to show human emotions it looks it looks
more robotic than you would think
robotic would even look
um so wait hang on in animation that's
called the what is it the erie valley or
the creepy
the uncanny valley the uncanny valley
yeah um and animation has found a way
where they're coming out of the uncanny
valley
they don't think ai will ever get out of
the uncanny valley because it is
something
really truly spiritual
human in the eyes
and when you see it you know it and
there's a lot of people that you can
talk to that just don't have that you
know they might feel sorry for you but
they're not those people that have real
empathy and you know the difference and
ai will never be able to compete with
that is that the weird moment that we're
in that everything you're describing
here
sounds like a dystopian movie most
likely or a book that was originally
written by philip k dick but i mean
everything you sound it's this sort of
sounds like minority report it sort of
sounds like terminator it sort of sounds
like irobot like we're rushing to a
matrix for sure that we're rushing
towards it we all have had all the
warnings the warning signs are all
behind us they were in books they were
in movies they're in history they're in
the bible they're all there and we're
just rushing it we're all going
well you know let's keep going because
right who's going to stop us
right and we all kind of know too yeah
we all feel something i don't care what
political stripe you are you're all we
all know something is really not right
something this is not gonna end well we
know it uh and you know what's what's
crazy is
uh
in many ways
the liberals were right
we were wrong we thought it would come
as you know some
communist marxist thing those guys are
being used this is coming through our
corporations
every time i watch a dystopian movie i
roll my eyes when they're like i work
for the corporation aka the government
i'm like ah stop it
that is what they're right and how the
left
is i'm against big pharmaceutical
companies really except for right now
when it comes
i mean it's crazy they knew all this
stuff we mocked them and now we're
standing where they were going guys
uh you were right i mean
can't you see this but you got to kind
of admire it right like not what it's
doing but the trick that it pulled right
there you got to admire that that these
people you've got as you're saying
they're the pawns these communists and
socialists and all these people they're
the pawns and the foot soldiers and they
think that they're against the power
while they literally are for all the
corporations they're for all of the
messaging i walk into target yesterday
to buy some cleaning supplies and there
is a massive black lives matter section
there and it's like you're fighting the
power really with that shirt and
sweatshirt and pants and shoes i think
in a hundred years dave this is going to
be studied in every government uh
program
uh that is you know trying to teach
about the history and government and
behavioral science
this is
this is the time that the world will
look back i think we're going to be
studied for a thousand years
especially
if we defeat it
no nation has ever defeated anything
like this
i think we could be
the exception to that rule but only if
we all wake up
don't go down the road of conspiracies
just get the actual facts because
they're worse than any anybody that
could come up with conspiracies online
these are true
and if you just do that remain calm work
on empathy don't play into their hands
we beat them and here's why i know this
have you ever seen the government
ever work this hard to silence people
and keep them in line i've never seen it
if they thought we were sheep
if they thought we couldn't stop it they
wouldn't care they wouldn't do any of
this but they are working over overtime
and they're talking now of probably
about at least 50 percent of the country
remember to change things it only it's
the tipping point is like 19 or 20
percent
they're talking about half of the nation
that's pretty significant and they know
it
have you in all the time you've been
talking about this and taken you know
dozens of callers every day on your
radio show and everything else have you
learned anything about the type of
person the makeup of the person or the
belief system of the person that is
willing to go into the fire and be the
guy in their social circle that's going
to talk about this stuff and change
people and everything else because i get
some version of this question a lot
people want they kind of get it but you
know they've got their job they kind of
get it but they've got their family they
they don't want to really get in but now
i think you're right we are getting to
this odd critical mass i mean when you
know and you've pushed canadians to do
what they're doing up there you know
something's wrong
they never they're never pissed off
about anything anything ever so what do
you what do you think is it what do you
think it is that that
we can do to help ignite that thing in
people not just know about the stuff but
that other thing the other thing so i
think the the easiest line to cross i
mean nancy pelosi chloe's saying it's
for the children it's for the children
uh so it's not about the children with
them it is about the children with
individual families and moms and dads
that's why you saw the pushback coming
at school that's why you saw i mean i
have friends who are very liberal
thought who could never have voted for
anybody but joe biden that are really
smoked right now and the tipping point
was you wait you want to vaccinate my
little my little ones are you kidding me
never
it is our children that speak to us that
make us much more
brave
but i think it's just connecting
we have to connect enough people
the week i release the book all i kept
hearing in my head was the eyes of the
world are upon you
that's what fda sorry that's what dwight
eisenhower said on the day of d-day to
the troops
the eyes of the world are upon you
and what you do today
will decide the freedom of men and women
all over the world
we need to get
to a place to where people understand
this is our world war two
this is
our opportunity is it going to be lost
in this generation
and if they really truly understand that
then they'll
be courageous because people with
children don't want my kids i have them
in 30s and i have them as teenagers
and the older ones have come to me and
went so dad
what is life going to be like now for my
kids
and my answer is
it's yet to be decided
if we do all that we're supposed to do
it will be fine we're gonna go through
really difficult times but we make it
out on the other end if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell